[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous passons notre vie à négocier tous
tout le temps et sans même nous en
rendre compte parfois ce soit avec nos
amis famille collègues patrons voire
même nos enfants
qu'est ce qu'on regarde ce soir sur
netflix est ce que je peux avoir une
augmentation est ce que je peux
travailler sur tel projet ou sur tel
autre
combien d'unités vous souhaitez monsieur
le client et à quel prix
en fait on négocie tout le temps 80% des
prises de décisions que nous prenons
sont faites en adéquation avec une autre
personne qui a la capacité de nous dire
non alors on pourrait penser que l'on
négocié comme on respire
c'est faux respirer est purement
intuitif négocier ne l'est clairement
pas négocier ça s'apprend ça s'apprend
si vous voulez défendre vos intérêts de
façon efficace et si vous voulez éviter
de vous retrouver dans la situation
absurde dans laquelle je suis
aujourd'hui
en fait un partant ce matin parce que
j'habille en bleu et par souci de
classicisme je voulais mettre des
chaussettes bleues et ma femme ce matin
m'a offert des chaussettes rouges en
référence au logo ted et comme j'étais
pressé et par souci de simplicité
j'ai fait un compromis
comme vous pouvez le voir le compromis
qui est communément répandue comme la
meilleure solution dans la négociation
ne l'est clairement pas en fait le
compromis c'est même la fausse bonne
idée de la négociation aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous inviter à repenser cette
notion de compromis dans la négociation
alors déjà on est en droit de se poser
la question qu'est ce qu'un compromis en
fait un compromis c'est que je vais
abandonner une partie de ce que je veux
l'autre va abandonner une partie de ce
qu'il veut pour créer une sorte de zone
d'accord possible et obtenir un accord
un peu gagnant un peu gagnant ou un peu
perdant un peu perdant ça dépend si on
voit le verre à moitié plein ou à moitié
vide mais vous comprenez bien que dans
cette notion de compromis on ne
satisfait pas pleinement son intérêt
voire même pire on va générer on va
créer une forme de tristesse frustration
déception à l'issue de la négociation
chez nous et chez l'autre
attention quand vous couper la poire en
deux à ne pas être là poids
cette notion de compromis n'a aucun sens
c'est comme si à la fin du ted pour me
reposer avec ma femme moi je décide
d'aller au restaurant elle préfère qu'on
aille se reposer au cinéma on va au
restaurant on prend et l'entrée on paye
et on va voir les 30 dernières minutes
du film
ça n'a aucun intérêt je m'appelle julien
p la berrichonne négociateurs
professionnels
c'est à dire que mon métier il est
d'accompagner forme et assister les
entreprises individus organisations dans
la conduite de leurs négociations les
plus sensibles et les plus complexes
aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager avec
vous trois principes issus de mes
travaux de recherche et de mon
expérience qui devrait vous aider à
mieux négocier tout en évitant le
compromis premier principe prendre le
contrôle de ses intuitions
pour moi il n'y a rien de pire que de
s'en remettre juste à son intuition dans
la négociation en fait s'en remettent
juste à son intuition dans la
négociation c'est prendre le risque de
passer complètement à côté de votre
négociation et de devoir faire dans le
meilleur des cas un compromis pour vous
rattraper
je vais vous montrer un exemple qui
étaient tirés des travaux daniel
kahneman prix nobel d'économie en 2002
si je vous dis une raquette
et une balle de tennis coûte 1 euro 10
une raquette et une balle de tennis
coûte 1 euro dans la raquette coûte 1
euro de plus que la balle combien coûte
là bas effectivement si la première idée
que vous avez en tête ces dix centimes
intuitivement c'est faux en fait la
balle coûte 5 centimes la raquette coûte
1 euro de plus que la balle 1 euros et 5
centimes 1 euros et 5 centimes et 5
centimes 1 euro disent vous voyez cette
première idée cette intuition qu'on a
elle est fausse et ça demande trois
choses à votre cerveau pour avoir bon du
temps de l'énergie et de la motivation
aidant beaucoup de négociations n'a pas
forcément du temps de l'énergie et de la
motivation et on a cette intuition qui
reprend le pas je partagerai avec vous
un exemple qui m'avait assez marqué à
l'époque j'étais à salariée d'un cabinet
de conseil
on reçoit un appel d'offres d'un
fournisseur d'un client qu'on connaît
très bien et le directeur commercial dit
moi je le connais très bien ce client je
sais exactement ce qu'ils veulent j'ai
cette intuition et donc on va prendre le
temps de qualifier cet appel d'offres
d'en parler avec le client pour savoir
exactement ce qu'ils souhaitent
le directeur commercial fait sa réponse
à appels d'offres et l'envoie soutenance
et dans la soutenance surprise le client
lui dit on est très surpris très étonné
de votre réponse
elle correspond pas complètement à nos
attentes et alors que l'appel d'offres
était composé de trois lots et on aurait
pu gagner les trois lots on a été obligé
de faire un compromis et de se
concentrer sur un seul lot pour le
gagner on a perdu deux lots sur 3 juste
à cause d'une intuition ça coûte cher
méfiez vous de votre intuition elle n'a
aucune raison logique d'être exacts même
si de temps en temps vous aurez bon
c'est un petit peu comme une horloge cas
c'est même une logique assez de leurs de
façon exacte deux fois par jour notre
méfiez vous de votre intuition au risque
de passer complètement à côté de votre
négociation
prenez le contrôle de ses intuitions de
vos intuitions
car toute négociation doit se préparer
et chacune de vos hypothèses devront
être challenger 2e étape
passer d'une volonté de convaincre à une
volonté de comprendre alors en parallèle
de mon activité conseil en négociation
j'ai la chance d'enseigner la
négociation à hec à l'ena et à la
sorbonne et quand je demande aux
étudiants qu'est ce qui les intéresse le
plus dans le module de négociations en
début de formation j'ai toujours la même
réponse nous apprendre à argumenter à
convaincre pour obtenir le plus possible
dans la négociation or paradoxalement
convaincre étant non sens dans la
négociation en fait convaincre c'est
vaincre et qu'on sait un préfixe
intensifs en est un qui veut dire deux
manières plus importante c'est à dire
qu'on veut annihiler l'autre juste par
sa parole quand j'essaye de convaincre
l'autre je lui explique à quel point il
a tort et à quel point j'ai raison hélas
le cerveau est plutôt bien fait parce
qu'en face vous aurez quasiment toujours
la même réaction
vous allez avoir quelqu'un qui va vous
écouter non pas pour comprendre votre
propos mais pour répondre avec cette
petite voix en tête attend deux secondes
de finir ta phrase et regarde ce que je
vais te mettre
et là il va vous dire à quel point la
raison et à quel point vous avez tort
vous comprenez bien que de cette
situation seule une victoire à la
pyrrhus peut se dessiner c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir toutes les métaphores
qu'on retrouve dans le management liés à
la guerre guerre de positions joutes
verbales
je veux gagner contre l'autre vous
pourriez obtenir un accord effectivement
mais à quel prix
ou à côté de quel accord bien meilleur
vous êtes passé je vous donne un exemple
qui est pas plus tard que fin de l'année
dernière je sorte conférences et j'ai un
chef d'entreprise qui vient me voir et
qui me dit julien j'ai un petit problème
il ya trois ans je me suis séparé d'un
de mes salariés qui travaillent aux
états unis et il ya trois ans il m'a
demandé quinze mille dollars
et la green card ce à quoi j'ai répondu
non
il ya deux ans il est allé encore tu
donc c'est l'équivalence des prud'hommes
aux états unis et il m'a demandé deux
cent mille dollars
ce à quoi j'ai répondu non
et l'année dernière la cohorte a rendu
un verdict en sa faveur
je lui dois sept cent mille dollars
quinze mille deux cent mille sept cent
mille dollars
qu'est-ce que je peux faire situation un
petit peu compliqué mais j'écoute a dit
mitch peux te proposer de faire une
médiation c'est à dire de retravailler
sur le lien qui vous unit
j'appelle ce salarié bonjour je
m'appelle chapet laberge négociateurs
professionnels et je souhaiterais vous
proposer une médiation
hélas sa réponse elle est très claire
écoutez une super la berre je ne savais
pas que ce métier à exister et si
j'avais su qu'il existait j'aurais fait
appel à vous il ya bien longtemps mais
ça va être une fin de non recevoir
ça veut dire non pourquoi j'irais en
médiation alors qu'aujourd'hui j'avais
ardite qui m'est favorable à hauteur de
700 milles de là là vous comprenez bien
qu'argumenter c'est foncer droit dans un
mur et donc au sein de notre institut on
a travaillé sur des méthodes de
questionnement sur des outils dont un
outil qui s'appelle sam peur qui est
basé sur des travaux sur l' écoute
active et donc pendant 1h15 1h20 j'ai
questionné pour comprendre qualité sa
représentation du problème qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient vécu comment est ce qu'il
leur santé est la dernière étape de
saveurs cr résumé des propos voilà ce
qui s'est passé donc si je comprends
bien ça fait trois ans que vous est
dédié à 100% sur ce procès que vous
percevez comme profondément injuste ce
procès a mis à mal votre équilibre
familial avec votre femme avec votre
fille et la rapatriement en france a été
extrêmement dur à gérer
au-delà de ça vous êtes tellement dédié
à ce procès aujourd'hui vous n'avez
toujours pas retrouvé travail et au delà
de cette somme d'argent qui est
considérable mais dont vous me dites
vous n'avez pas forcément besoin c'est
pas ça qui vous fera tourner la page ce
qui vous fera tourner la page c'est
d'être assis face à face face à votre
ancien employeur le regarder droit dans
les yeux et lui dire à quel point vous
avez souffert de cette situation que
vous percevez comme profondément injuste
et à partir de ce moment là le fardeau
qui est sur vos épaules ne vous
appartiendra plus
et là il me répond un mot magique dans
la négociation il me répond c'est vrai à
ce moment-là il venait de reconnaître
que j'avais reconnu son problème à ce
moment-là il venait de reconnaître que
j'avais compris sa perception de la
situation à ce moment là il venait de
légitimer ma négociations il venait de
me donner le droit de commencer à
négocier et en cinq minutes on a eu un
accord pour aller en médiation sans
aucune forme de compromis mais vous
comprenez bien que j'avais argumenté de
quel droit j'aurais pu lui dire ce qui
était bien ou pas bien pour lui
comprendre est primordiale car il vous
permettra derrière le nom qui est
affichée d'aller chercher un oui d'aller
chercher un vrai oui d'aller chercher un
oui sans compromis chercher à augmenter
l'autre alors je dois ce credo à un de
mes mentors en négociation eric blondeau
ce que la négociation en gros c'est
comment faire en sorte que l'autre
accepte librement ma proposition mais
avec son système de pensée est pour ça
ça n'est possible que si je cherche à
l'augmenter que si je cherche dans son
référentiel un futur bénéfice pour lui à
aller sur l'accord j'ai eu la chance
d'accompagner être formés à mon
référentiel de négociations la cellule
de négociation d'une unité
d'intervention de la police nationale
les gens que vous voyez cagoulés en noir
à la télévision et quand ils négocient
avec un forcené à aucun moment il lui
demande de sortir
par contre il faut comprendre que sortir
est la meilleure solution qui s'impose à
lui et c'est très différent
ils ne peuvent se permettre ça qu en
allant chercher un futur bénéfices dans
la reddition pour le forcené
je vais vous donner un exemple j'ai vécu
il ya 18 mois avec une enseigne de
bricolage leader mondial qui a fait
appel à moi sur une négociation
l'acheteuse seniors qui venait de
récupérer un compte au bout de trois
semaines son fournisseur lui dit on
souhaite augmenter nos prix de 5% et
elle m'a dit mais julien à partir de
combien de %
ça sera une bonne négociation et
si je trouve un accord à 4% c'est bien
est ce que si on fait un compromis à
deux et demi pour cent c'est mieux
est-ce que je peux aller jusqu'à 1 % et
donc on prépare cette négociation est
dans les axes de préparation de cette
négociation
je vous demande déjà d'aller questionner
sur les 5 % quel est l'historique de ces
5 % comment est-ce que ce prix a été
construit calculé sur quels critères
objectifs et deuxièmement d'aller
comprendre derrière la motive derrière
la position
quelle est la motivation quels sont les
intérêts qui sont en jeu pour son
interlocuteur
premier rendez vous a lieu et elle
revient avec les informations alors
apparemment le prix de + 5 %
correspondrait au prix de l'évolution du
prix de l'acier sur les dernières années
on vérifie sur les dernières années le
prix de l'évolution de l'acier c'était
plus 2% donc pas forcément corrélés et
quand je me demande quelle est sa
motivation autant d'interlocuteurs
hamadi ben voilà c'est une personne qui
a récupéré le comte france est
aujourd'hui le souhaiteraient augmenter
le chiffre d'affaires de 500 mille euros
sur un compte à 10 millions ça fait 5 %
et en plus elle a pour ambition demain
d'avoir une responsabilité européenne y
est mieux avec toute la partie europe du
sud donc on travaille sur comment
augmenter notre partenaire dans la
négociation et un moment donné on
s'aperçoit qu'ils sont extrêmement
mauvais sur la supply chain et la
logistique
c'est à dire que régulièrement en
magasin on a des références qui ne sont
pas à jour ou qui ne sont pas en rayon
et quand on fait les commandes
ça peut prendre entre une semaine et
deux semaines pour ça arrive en magasin
et quand on calcule le manque à gagner
le manque à gagner est quasiment quatre
cent mille euros quasiment ce qu'ils
demandaient on a de la chance on
organise une deuxième réunion de
négociations au siège social de cette
entreprise qui est en allemagne
et voici comment ça s'est passé vous
nous avez demandé une augmentation de 5%
et on ne souhaite pas y donner suite
par contre on s'est rendu compte que
tous les ans vous perdiez 500000 euros
et ça c'est à cause de votre logistique
et supply chain
or nous
on a une véritable expertise sur la
supply chain et la logistique est ce
qu'on souhaiterait vous proposez c'est
de vous former à la logistique de
repenser cette chaîne logistique et
d'après nos calculs entre si c'est lui
moi vous devriez pouvoir rattraper ce
manque à gagner de 500 mille euros par
an et même mieux si vous capitaliser sur
notre expertise
c'est quelque chose que vous pourriez
utiliser sur l'europe du sud avec qui
vous travaillez déjà espagne portugal
italie et là on est d'augmenter notre
partenaire on est passé d'une
négociation de plus 5% à 0 % sans aucun
compromis
et pour la petite histoire quelques mois
après il négocier même une remise de
prix négative c'est à vannes cela
n'avait été possible que parce que nous
avons cherché à augmenter notre
partenaire vous avez bien compris pour
moi
la négociation s'est pas intuitif et
pour être performant ça s'apprend je
suis persuadé que la négociation que
savoir bien négocier c'est même un enjeu
ou un enjeu sociétal bien savoir
négocier déjà dans notre prisme de la
sphère professionnelle de l'entreprise
c'est s'assurer une performance
économique à travers le prisme de la
performance sociale et dans notre sphère
familiale privée bien négocier ces
gagnants quiétude et en sérénité
alors aujourd'hui à travers cette
conférence je fais le voeu que vous
puissiez gagné inquiétudes sérénité et
efficacité sur vos prochaines
négociations
et pour ça je vous propose trois choses
prenez le contrôle de vos intuitions
passer d'une volonté de convaincre à une
volonté de comprendre et chercher à
augmenter votre partenaire merci
[Applaudissements]